لم تعد هذه الفتره من السنه تمثل ذروه
ايام العمل لدى سيرجي ففي موسم الحصاد كان
هذا الطريق يغص بالشاحنات ذهابا وايابا
الى موانئ اوديسا لنقل الحبوب الى مختلف
دول العالم اختلف الحال بعد خروج روسيا من
اتفاقيه
الحبوب الطريق طويل نحو الموانئ النهريه
وحتى بعد وصوله امامه كثير من الظ فلا باس
في قسط من
الراحه العام الماضي كان الوضع افضل بكثير
والحجوزات على نقل الحبوب كانت اكثر الان
الطلبيات قليله واسعار الشحن تدنت الموانئ
النهريه لا تستطيع استيعاب كل هذه
الكميات تعمل اوكرانيا على ايجاد طرق
بديله لايصال حبوبها الى العالم اهمها
تفعيل الطرق النهريه عبر مينائي اسماعيل
ورينيه على نهر الدانوب نحو ميناء سولينا
الروماني على البحر الاسود اضافه الى
تفعيل الطرق البريه عبر رومانيا ومولدوفا
وخصصت دول البلطيق خمسه موانئ لنقل الحبوب
الاوكرانيه كما اتفقت كيف مع كرواتيا على
استخدام موانئها على الدانوب وعلى البحر
الادرياتيكي خيارات متعدده لكن تكتنف
صعاب
كثيره مؤخرا قصفت البنيه التحتيه لموانئ
النهريه وبالتالي لا يمكن القول انها امنه
خصصت الدوله اكثر من 500 مليون دولار
سنويا لتامين السفن بشكل عام موانئ
البلطيق تحتاج الى تعزيز البنيه التحتيه
ومرور الحبوب لابد ان يكون عبر بولندا
التي تخشى من ان تصل الى اسواقها ويتضرر
مزارعها تدرك كيف ان كل البدائل لا تعوض
طرق النقل البحري عبر موانئ اوديسا على
البحر الاسود ويبدو ان هذا دفعها الى
تفعيل ممرات بحريه وصفتها بالانسانيه
لاجلاء السفن العالقه منذ بدايه الحرب
بعيدا عن اتفاقيه الحبوب وعن التوافق مع
موسكو خطوه قد تلقي بالكره في ملعب حلف
شمال
الاطلسي يمكننا ضمان سلامه السفن في
المياه الاقليميه الخاصه بنا اما بعد
خروجها من منطقتنا لا نستطيع تقديم ضمانات
للسفن في المياه الاقليميه لثلاث دول
اعضاء في النيتو وهي رومانيا وبلغاريا ثم
تركيا انتهى الاوكرانيين حتى الان من حصاد
نحو 20 مليون طن من الحبوب معظمها في
اوديسا وميكو الايف وتتوقع وزاره السياسات
الزراعيه ان يصل محصول هذا العام الى نحو
70 مليون طن ستبحث لها عن موانئ تنقلها
الى دول العالم تستهل لك اوكرانيا 20 في
فقط من انتاجها من الحبوب وعدم قدرتها على
تصدير هذا الفائض يمثل لها مشكله اقتصاديه
لكنها بالنسبه للملايين حول العالم تمثل
مشكله امن غذائي في كوكب يعاني ع في المه
من سكانه من الجوع ر لافي الجزيره اوديسا